check out Karin jeanpierre we're going
to show her from this week and then it's
going to show what she was saying two
weeks ago um a couple weeks ago you had
said what we're seeing at the border
isn't unusual but in the month of
December there were more than 302,000
migrant encounters uh the highest total
for a single month ever recorded So does
the administration concede that what
we're seeing now is unusual what I said
was to be exact is that what we're
seeing at the US is is uh is es and
flows and how many migrants arrive at
the border it's something that happens
every year it es and flows and what
we're seeing here at the border the
migration flow uh increased migration
flow certainly uh it you know it es and
flows and we're at a time of the year
where we're seeing more uh at the border
and it's not unusual this is an
immigration system that has been broken
for
decades I will give her some sort of
credit there in that she did say two
weeks ago that it ESB and flows but Ane
she's treating immigration as if it's
weather like oh yes it's December and
it's a little bit colder and when we get
like this is just complete nonsense and
it's irrelevant we either have a border
or we
don't well it's no surprise that she
would downplay the seriousness of what's
been happening because immigration when
it's made as a an issue for voters uh
that doesn't de that does not benefit
Ben um benefit the Democrat Party
so I mean it's unfortunate that it's had
to take such an long ongoing crisis for
for the administration to be asked more
and more uh my the longer questions I
have though is what can this or the next
Administration do I mean even you know
reminder even under the Trump
Administration a a complete a border
wall was unable to take place and so
this this is an issue that seems going
to be with America because of our our
our politics uh potentially indefinitely
I don't know there's a will really to um
to shut down the the pathways and routes
for Mass illegal migration to the US you
know it's not and people often think
about it's like as Colin said it's
numbers 20,000 200,000 500,000 million
these numbers just become kind of
abstract when you see them as numbers
but the impact um on on housing on
resources the significant strain on
taxpayer funds that are needed to house
and to feed and to
educate um all these people who come in
and of course there's a security issue
as well when people are coming in um
usually with no documents uh because
they destroy their identity papers so
you don't even know who who they even
are so it's uh um unfortunately this is
uh it seems like a problem
that's there's no will in either really
party or way um to to stop
well